[Music]
hey here we are back again yeah we went
ahead and watched uh the 1984 fire
starter just for just to compare and
contrast just to compare with the other
one
yeah okay
it's it's kind of like i remembered um
some of the problems i had with the fir
with with the new movie
like uh the fire suits and [ __ ] is
homaging scenes out of this movie yeah i
had forgotten that they haven't
forgotten about thermal like yeah
heat suits in the original yeah the shop
got the guys from the shop uh the
[ __ ] secret agents they would show up
in those damn
fire retardant suits and hopes it would
help them it didn't help them though she
cooked them anyway
they just like baked potatoes inside
yeah
yeah
it was a pretty good movie um
not a modern movie a movie of its time
uh the
the edit kind of bogs down in a certain
places where and i see why they changed
it in the new one
um
the old one is kind of closer to the
book
from what i remember the book yeah
and uh just like anything else sometimes
that doesn't work very well in a movie
um
they did have the time span about right
i think didn't they it seemed like they
did yeah
they like they they were better like
conveying that like and the weird thing
about it i do like this movie but i will
note that i don't think it's one of the
best stephen king adaptations
particularly from that time period and
the interesting thing about it and i
didn't really realize this until i was
uh researching the 1984 film was that
this got really shitty reviews when it
came out too and stephen king did not
like it really yeah he just thought it
was he thought um drew barrymore was
good in it
but he didn't like david keith the guy
that played andy mcgee the dad um he
thought he was
he just thought he wasn't like he was uh
too hammy or something like that okay
and um
yeah so there was a lot of stuff about
it he didn't like interestingly here's
another thing i didn't know
was that john carpenter was supposed to
direct this okay
and he actually had a screenwriter do
him and uh the screenwriter kind of like
worked together and they did an
adaptation they changed a lot of stuff
from the novel but i'm not entirely sure
what
but uh it seemed like a good movie
stephen king like approved of it even
though he changed a lot of stuff from
the novel but then
the thing came out john carpenter's
thing and very famously kind of tanked
at the box office yeah unjustifiably
unjustifiably obviously because it's
[ __ ] classic
but you know it's his best movie
but the thing about it is that after
that happened they're like okay well we
don't want you to direct firestarter now
so they actually ended up getting mark
lester
who was more of like an action movie guy
or like she's he did commando
he did uh roller boogie he did class of
1984. so not so much you know he was
kind of like more an action movie guy or
like a cheesy kind of guy
and
i mean okay so
take trying to take nostalgia out of the
equation because i was trying to do that
when i was like i've seen this movie
multiple times but it's been a long time
since i've seen it
and so i was trying to look at it with
through like an objective lens
now i will say that i think the 1984 one
is a better adaptation
and is a better movie in general
but
there are some changes that they made in
the new one that i think were probably
better
you know what i'm saying i understand
why they did it when you look yeah when
you look at the old one the pacing
they're pacing problems with this
it's a little long yeah it's long it
slows down especially when they're in
captivity and some of the stuff that
they did when they were on the run was
kind of like
yeah why are they even bothering showing
this you know what i mean it's just kind
of like empty
kind of like action but i guess they had
to show them on the run it's just that
some of the stuff that they did on the
run just wasn't all that exciting
um it's it's it's a classic movie though
yeah and uh score is good tangerine
dream does the score yeah i really like
the score of this one and i'm listening
to it and i'm going like man that sounds
like john carpenter
you know
and john carpenter did the score on the
new one yeah and you said he was
supposed to direct this one yeah maybe
tangerine dream is slightly homaging
john carpenter because that score
sounded like something that john
carpenter would have come up with
yeah i really actually didn't sound like
tangerine
not yeah not generally because they did
do a lot of uh movie scores around this
uh time period i think they ended up
doing like 20 odd movies i think yeah
they did scores for but and i usually
like them but yeah this doesn't sound
exactly like their regular stuff it does
sound a little more carpenter sounds
like carpenter
uh it you know good movie you know for
what it is like it said like i said it's
a middling kind of time it's like a
stephen king movie in the middle
for the adaptations
i put it like maybe just a little bit
below
dead zone
uh i think it's kind of a lot below dead
zone i mean dead zone and christine
were i mean but you know dead zone was
cronenberg for christ's sake and
christine was john carpenter um so
obviously those are going to be a lot
better a lot of the same people in it
though that's true all right i would and
and
it it's it's not that i mean i put it
below dead zone but not a whole lot
below it it's real similar the way it's
shot just you know well martin sheen is
is playing essentially the same
character pretty much in this movie is
he well i just martin sheen was actually
not supposed it was supposed to be bert
lancaster yeah in that role but then
like he got sick or he had heart surgery
or something like that so martin sheen
kind of came in at the last minute and
he actually
plays kind of like um yeah stillson the
guy that he played in dead zone the
politician um he kind of plays a similar
kind of role
uh so
i don't know he he's a little over the
top in this but that was kind of his
thing so that so that was like fine
but i just i found it really interesting
because
people are like complaining about the
new fire starter which like i'm saying i
don't think it's a great movie by any
stretch it's you know it's meh but it
was fine and but people said the exact
same thing about the original one when
it came out in 84. like roger ebert said
it was boring
um you know a lot of people thought that
the guy that played um that played andy
was like was too hammy or like too over
the top
um kind of [ __ ] like that and a lot of
people really didn't like that it sort
of like was too long and like sagged in
the middle yeah so
rogers i agree with him it's a little
bit boring it's a little slow in certain
spots
but it was memorable that's the weird
thing about the movie i uh
there's a lot of good scenes in it and a
lot of good ideas that you remember
uh after you know especially if you're a
kid watching it you know like certain
abilities that that they did you know
making making the martin sheen what's
the name of the character martin sheen's
character in this one do you remember uh
full cat hollister captain captain
hollister it was the same as the woman
that the it was the same character yeah
he pushes the woman he's in captivity
and he pushes hollister to let him go
and to arrange the helicopter and to
give up all the information then in the
end he pushes hollister to fight
fight uh rain bird
and he did it yeah like or to shoot him
anyway yeah yeah yeah they were fighting
him that's the same you know like in
order to and i was just like yeah and he
died doing that and uh they both got
killed they got shot right now but uh i
forgot about that and there's a there's
a bunch of cool [ __ ] that happens you'd
be like man that'd be cool to be able to
do that just to [ __ ] take some dude
who a minute ago was gonna kill you and
then all of a sudden get him on your
side and to make him [ __ ]
fight one of his own guys
you know to defend you that's that's
[ __ ]
that's [ __ ]
that'd be a powerful [ __ ] ability
yeah
i mean okay so the thing about this one
that i had kind of forgotten about
was that whereas the new one is as we
said it's a lot more condensed i think
it's only like 90 something minutes
whereas this one is almost like pushing
two hours
but the new one kind of compresses time
so it happens like in a brief period of
time
there's no like captivity period or
anything like that which goes on for a
long time and it tells the story like
more or less chronologically like it
does the whole flashback like how
uh you know andy and vicky got their
powers like they just do that in the
opening credits and then they just move
pretty much right to you know where the
kid is 11. now in the original movie she
was eight
but um yeah so it's better that she's a
little bit older
yeah although the weird thing about it
and this is a weird thing too and i was
thinking about this when we were
re-watching the movie last night
even though the girl that plays charlie
in the new one
is less likeable because she's a little
bit older and we were saying oh she's a
little bit darker
but in the original drew barrymore who
was cute as [ __ ] button and is much
younger and seems a lot more innocent
she kills way more people she has like a
way higher body count than the girl in
the new movie does um but and yet but
she's still more sympathetic is that
weird that's really weird yeah just i
was thinking about that when i was
watching it it's because of the movie
and that it was also kind of
kind of uh more like an action movie
like something out of commando i guess
you know and there they were
the bad guys were more clear-cut bad
guys i guess you could say in the
original in the 84 one yeah um because
you know they were in captivity and i
think that that but not in the new one
so it was a little more ambiguous of
what was happening sometimes
um
and rain bird killed some guys
on his own side which he does kind of go
rogue in the old one but the thing is is
the way it ends and certain certain
things that happened
in the new one that's only about half
the story
which makes me believe that they that
they when they made this this movie they
intended to do two of them
yeah and i was reading some other
reviews and then it was like the av club
said this this seemed like um like a cbs
tv movie or part of or part of like a
two-part series yeah from 2003
oh it's not that bad ouch
that's what they said
well okay but one thing i did like i do
like about the original one a lot more
um even though it's not told in
chronological order like it pretty much
starts out um after the mom is dead and
uh andy and charlie are like on the run
and they're running away and kind of you
know the story is kind of like told in a
little bit of flashback which is fine um
the chronological way of approaching it
was fine too i don't really have a
preference
they're both like pretty clear
but the original one the ending of it is
way way better because
as i said charlie in the original drew
barrymore she kills [ __ ] everybody in
this because in the new one like when
all the cops come to the old couple's
house
rain bird kills all those cops in the
new one yeah in the old one charlie
kills them all yeah like she just burns
them all up like burns them alive and
you know so and she feels bad about it
but she still does that and then at the
end of the movie
she kills
god that had to be like hundreds and
hundreds of people but it's like a
really big it's like a carry ending yeah
really where it's just i mean she burns
[ __ ] everything down blows up a
helicopter blows up a helicopter blows
up that whole entire house like
fireballs shooting everywhere and [ __ ]
like that and all of that was practical
effects too so that the ending of the
original is a lot better like is a lot
more epic i felt like the ending of the
new one like she just kind of like
breaks into the facility in the new one
and burns up some people
and then gets out and then burns the
place down like in the background
but in the original like you see people
like getting hit with [ __ ] fireballs
and like flying up and down
[ __ ] like there wasn't a big ending in
the in the new one where you know she's
just fighting this whole [ __ ] unit of
them you know yeah where her dad's like
burn it all down yeah she's like
and just the way it ended i don't want
to spoil the ending just the way it
ended i'm like well [ __ ]
that can't be the end
yeah
so well yeah that was my main issue
with the new one was just like i said it
was totally unresolved it was fine up to
that but like the end was just left like
really ambiguous yeah yeah like okay
that's the end of part one yeah but uh
yeah they were trying to they were
trying to pull like an it chapter one in
chapter one
i'm thinking that's what they were
trying to do
this which means that there's room
in this story to actually have a second
movie that's better than the first one
depending on how they play it
it did it it's deviated from the book a
lot yeah
but not as much as i thought a lot of
the stuff that they showed in this movie
is mentioned in the first one but not
but not shown it's like it's sometimes
focusing on things that didn't happen
like the new one talks about
what what it was like when she was in
school well they actually show that in
the new one what happened at school
yeah because it's only mentioned yeah
there's like a couple of scenes where
she's in school and she's getting picked
on and right so there's
the focus
in the new movie it focuses on different
elements
of the book i guess that the the the 84
version this version didn't focus on
yeah it's the same story
mostly just the emphasis is on different
things that weren't weren't always
talked about i guess in in the
in the 84 movie
so it's just another way of doing it
i'm i'm still open-minded about it i
mean you know uh
set to see what happens i just
definitely not finished i do like the 84
one better um obviously but it has
problems too yeah i kind of feel like
there's a good because i mean the book
fire starter that's a really good book
and it's usually like
um it seems to be up there with people's
favorite uh stephen king novels from
this era
yeah i liked it a lot too and so i kind
of feel like there's a really good film
adaptation in there somewhere but the
thing about it is that just like with a
lot of stephen kings and i i think this
is why like you know adaptations of his
work tend to be so hit or miss
is that so much of his novels you know
most of which are very long obviously
have to do with people's internal
thoughts and feelings like stuff going
on inside people's heads yeah and that's
really really hard to convey
in a movie yeah which is why they
usually have to change so much so george
c scott rain bird
seeing it again did kind of bring back
some memories i was right he was he
wanted to kill her
so he could inherit her power in the
afterlife yeah kind of like how
the overlook hotel could could inherit
your your shine you know after you're
dead
he wanted to do that
and he thought that if he
that if he killed her at like that at
like a precise moment where she was the
most happy
that he could
collect on her [ __ ] soul i guess
or her power in the afterlife and he and
he said he would die soon
yeah he seemed to have some kind of
weird like religious thing yeah or
spiritual thing where native american
thing i think in the book yeah and they
left out i i remembered it had kind of
like a like a pedestrian undertone
it's got not there as much as i thought
it was i mean he does like put his hand
on her thigh and like he it is creepy
yeah i will say that george c scott was
a lot scarier like he was a lot more
threatening
because you knew that he was a bad guy
and there was like a long a lot of
interaction between them the new one
i did like that they actually won that
they actually got a real indigenous
person to play that character but i also
like that they gave him a little bit of
a backstory i'm not really i don't know
if i'm a and they gave him kind of his
own powers but they kind of made him a
little bit of a victim too
because he had also been [ __ ] over
by the shop like they he like he had
been given lot six
before
vicky and andy like so he was like an
earlier trial
and he might have been in the book it
might have been i can't remember i think
in the book i think he did have
paranormal abilities i believe i think
he did i have to look that up i didn't
remember him having paranormal powers
but
i don't know i did kind of believe he
could steal their souls that's true and
they thought they were saying you're
crazy he's like yeah
but i think he actually did believe that
maybe there was something to that
i mean if if the if the hou this is the
stephen king universe
if a [ __ ] hotel can do it why
couldn't a damn indian shaman
basically what they're saying he is
like a shaman
yeah
he was also ex-military and all kinds of
stuff i think if i remember in the book
i think he was special forces in vietnam
and
did some other stuff and i think he was
psychic or it hinted that he was psychic
in the book
but well you know
i also and yeah and i liked too in the
new version and i'm not saying that i
think the new version is better in a lot
of ways but i like some of the
storytelling decisions they made better
even if they weren't that well executed
i did like that i didn't like them
kind of not because i liked the whole
aspect of rain bird
pretending to be a good guy to like get
into charlie's good graces and stuff
which they didn't do in the new movie um
like i said i think it made him scarier
because the audience knows he's a bad
guy but charlie is trusting and doesn't
know that he's a bad guy but i did like
that they made rain bird more directly
uh they inserted him more directly into
the story by being the one that had
killed charlie's mother
in the original because i thought that
he had killed the mom in the original
movie too but that is not the case
uh the mother was actually just killed
by two random dudes from the shop yeah
and interestingly in the original
um andy doesn't kill those guys he just
blinds them
uh in the new one he absolutely does
kill them
yeah uh so
yeah so the new one has like some darker
aspects to it as far as character
motivations go
but
i don't know some of the stuff in the
new adaptation like made more sense
story-wise for the story they were
trying to tell like i said i do
i do like that they gave rain bird more
of motivation
um as being kind of like he
got [ __ ] over by the shop but then
they gave him a job and then they kind
of like threw him away but then they're
bringing him back like under new
auspices but he's still
kind of a rogue element and sort of is
doing what they want like just in
service of like destroying them from
within essentially is what he's trying
to do because he's like trying to get
revenge on them as well so i thought
that was an interesting yeah the take on
the two rain birds are different
yeah and
the george c scott one it's it's it's
good i like it yeah he's way scary i
mean he can he can do anything yeah i
mean that's sure she's [ __ ] scott i
like the new one though too i thought he
looked cool
the back story
some of the [ __ ] that he did was pretty
cool there wasn't enough of him
in the movies yeah that was the only
thing he didn't have very many lines
okay yeah which if there's a second one
maybe they'll remedy that i don't know
yeah because they yeah they really are
going to have to because like we said
they changed it a lot they changed at
that point yeah so i mean if you're
going to change it that much then
you better be [ __ ] good with it then
you better know where that story's going
yeah
because i don't know
i'm not entirely sure how i feel about
the ending i mean i'd i'd be willing to
like see a second part to this to see
where what they do with it because i'm
curious yeah okay like well i'm not
going to spoil everything but look the
way the moo the new one ends it's as if
rain bird wins
yeah essentially yeah i don't think he
does though i think i think it's just uh
it was the end of part one
did you notice too another thing that
the new movie changed this is like a
hugely significant change so i'm kind of
wondering why they made it i thought in
the new one it was implied
that andy and vicky the mom and dad that
they already had some latent psychic
abilities before they took lot 6 and
that like brought it out
whereas i feel like in the original
movie and maybe the book i can't
remember
the the drug actually gave them those
psychic powers am i wrong about that
from what i remember in the book
most people that ta that took the real
lot six during that test
um
kind of went crazy yeah dude tore's eyes
out and once it went yeah they did that
in the in the new one and the old one
yeah and they did that it didn't work
but but those two
yeah
for some reason they they came back with
abilities
but i don't remember if
yeah yeah that's that's right yeah they
came back with abilities and i i don't
remember exactly what they did with them
though i guess they put them in custody
because they they've escaped right well
the thing about now this was just like a
throwaway line but like i said i was
really trying to like pay attention to
the old one because i've seen it before
but i had forgotten and i was like
trying to compare and contrast the two
now in the original one the mom now
that's another thing i like about the
new one is that at least they gave the
mom like more of a role before she got
murdered because heather locklear played
the mom in the present she was in it for
like a minute yeah seriously she was
hardly in it she was like in the in the
scene where they met like at the trial
and then she would got her hands burned
and then she was dead like in the closet
but the thing about it is that
i don't know like
i don't know i just feel like it was
like a really weird
what was i
i was going somewhere with that and i
totally forgot like where i was going
with it because i got distracted by the
by the thing about like um the mom what
did you just ask me what did you just
ask me whether if they had psychic
abilities before the uh uh uh
they took a lot six or nine that yeah
that's true it's been so long that i've
read the book i'm not i'm not sure oh oh
i know what i was gonna say i know what
i was gonna say um okay so in the new
movie there's here's another thing that
i liked in the new movie they kind of
make it they they give an excuse why the
family doesn't have cell phones or wi-fi
or anything like that because they don't
want the shop tracking them because the
shop don't know where they are yeah and
they have to keep moving around in the
original movie
i thought that heather locklear before
drew barrymore set her hands on fire
said something about
um you know they know where we are or
you know they they're keeping us here
something like that so i was under the
impression
that the shop knew where they were but
was just like making them stay there to
keep an eye on them you know what i'm
saying i think they didn't the that andy
and charlie at least that was the
impression i got didn't go on the run
until
um
until vicky got murdered
right it seemed like i think they went
on the run because um a woman
in the in the old one
in the old one they went on the run
because no no no no no
charlie set fire to the school
remembrance she was going to come under
investigation that's why they ran well
in the new one and the
new one well because the shop remember
because the shop was monitoring
everywhere because they didn't know
where they were because in the new one
they made it very clear like i said that
they did not have cell phones they
didn't have wi-fi they kept changing
their names in the original movie we're
led to believe that those were their
actual names like the mcgees in the new
one they have all these because when
they finally catch andy
you know she lists off all his aliases
so they've been like moving around
trying to hide from them but when she is
at school and like does the explosion
like in the bathroom
um they catch it like on thermal imaging
camera or whatever and they're like
from a satellite and they're like oh we
need to check that out because because
that might be where that kid is that
they were trying to find we're looking
for them i kind of felt like in the
original one they seemed like they knew
where they were yeah i don't know
man it just
maybe they did it because it seemed like
i'm retired i can't yeah i can't
remember exactly what heather locklear
said but she had a line like when they
were all in the kitchen that it's like
you know we're right where you know
we're right where they want us or you
know they can find us or something like
that so i was led to believe that the
shop
knew where they were and was like kind
of monitoring them or they knew they
were being monitored
but then you know when they killed vicki
when they killed the mom
um
then it was just kind of like then they
went on the run whereas pri whereas the
new one
they made it very clear that they have
been in hiding like the whole time draw
dogs is mentioned in the television
series yeah they keep trying to get us
to see it on that little service that
she has peacock
well peacock was it yeah it is on
peacock actually that's what we watched
the um
because they they have fire starter 84
that's where we watch that i don't know
if it's any good or not it's from 2002
yeah it's from the sci-fi channel and
it's basically charlie like has grown
over there's like a hot 20 something
just yeah um so i don't know it might be
okay because remember how
we didn't even know that there was a
dead zone series yeah it was pretty good
and then actually we watched it i was
like wow that was actually really really
good yeah that was from what early to
mid 2000s early 2000s yeah i think i got
it all i got it on dvd yeah if you
haven't seen it anthony michael hall is
in it yeah um playing johnny smith and
uh it was actually like way better than
i was expecting i was expecting it to be
like really really [ __ ] but it was
actually like really really good yeah
but so i don't know if i don't know if
the
it's called fire starter rekindled yeah
but yeah it was made for sci-fi but yeah
it's just i don't know so
seeing the first one though i'm glad we
watched it because i was like really
instructive
to see like how this it's essentially
the same story but it's just they
tweaked it they structured it
differently they changed a couple
people's backstories they gave
they get some people in the new ones i
feel like they gave them like better
motivation for doing particular things
although i do wish they had done more in
the new one with rain bird i did like
the some stuff they did like with his
backstory
but
he didn't have a whole lot
yeah he wasn't in it enough yeah because
in the original one like pretty much the
whole second half of the movie yeah is
rain bird and charlie like it because
charlie's in you know she's locked up at
the shop and so he's like trying to get
into her good graces and so they
interact a lot more whereas this one he
seems a lot more like um
he seems like less of a character and
more just kind of like yeah and it ends
on a cliffhanger where it looks like
brain bird won but i don't i it's got to
be the end of part one of the first
movie i mean it's got to be that it's
got to be so there has to be more to it
coming
but um
that's all that's really all i gotta say
because i mean the original had such
like an epic like definitive ending
right with all that [ __ ] great this
one was just like no that was not really
an end
one thing i kind of like too is that
in the original the i i mean i love um
the old couple that you know picks them
up which was art carney and uh louise
fletcher by the way
and but i will say that i kind of like
that the new one
gave that old guy like more of a reason
for picking them up i think like in the
original movie he was just like a nice
old farmer and he's like hey i'm gonna
pick up some hitchhikers
uh and take him back to my house and
then it turns out that he's like
supposedly a fugitive
whereas in the new one um they make it
clear that andy has to push him to get
him to pick them up because the guy
doesn't really want to do it and then
there's also like a kind of a nice
little subplot
where which i kind of wish they'd
expanded on a little bit but in the new
one
the guy has a wife who's like um
she was in a car accident and she can't
talk so she's like in a it's not she's
not in a coma but you know she can't
talk or anything like that and um so
the reason that the old guy whose name's
irv i think yeah he was an irv in both
versions and the reason that the old guy
is so um
so like wants to protect them after that
is that charlie like shows that she can
psychically know what his wife is saying
and can tell him
like because she knows all the stuff
about him so i kind of like that they
did that whereas in the original one as
much as i like them in it and i like
them as characters better in the new one
they had like he had more of a
motivation i think for like helping them
you know what i'm saying
martin sheen's son emilio estevez was in
maximum overdrive which had some great
music by ac dc yeah we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to review that one of
these days he said maybe he's [ __ ]
it's so movies terrible it's terrible
but it's also quite awesome
it's so terrible that it's awesome
all right you uh you seem like you're
done talking yeah i got it to the
restroom
all right
all right so
we will be back uh tomorrow evening for
our regular show we're actually talking
about the australian folk hero slash
cultural
icon ned kelly which several of you have
recommended
uh so yeah we're finally getting around
to that tomorrow night it should be a
fun show so as always thanks for
dropping by to see us today and we'll
see you guys tomorrow afternoon or
evening
bye